I'm moving now to the second half of
linear algebra
it's about eigenvalues and eigenvectors
the first half I just had a matrix I
solved equations the second half you'll
see the point of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors as a new way to look deeper
into the matrix to see what's important
there okay so what are they this is a
big equation s times X so s is our
matrix and I've called it s because I'm
taking it to be a symmetric matrix
what's what's on one side of the
diagonal is also on the other side of
the diagonal so those have the beautiful
properties those are the kings of linear
algebra now about eigen vectors X and
eigen values lambda so what does that
equation SX equal lambda X tell me that
says that I have a special vector X when
I multiply it by s my matrix
I'm stay in the same direction as the
original X it might get multiplied by 2
lambda could be 2
it might get multiplied by 0 lambda
could even be 0
it might get multiplied by minus 2
whatever but it's along the same line so
that's like taking a matrix and turning
discovering inside it something that's
all that stays on a line that means that
it's really a sort of one dimensional
problem if we're looking at along that
eigen vector and that makes computations
infinitely easier so the hard part of a
matrix is all the all the connections
between different rows and columns so
eigenvectors are the guys that stay in
that same direction so and and there's y
is another eigenvector it has its own
eigenvalue it got multiplied by alpha
where SX multiplied the x by some other
number lambda so those are a couple of
eigenvectors and the beautiful fact is
because s is symmetric those two eigen
vectors are perpendicular there
orthogonal as it says up there so
symmetric matrices are really the best
because they're eigen vectors are
perpendicular and we have a bunch of
one-dimensional problems and here I've
included a proof do you want to proof
that the eigen vectors are perpendicular
so what does perpendicular mean it means
that X transpose times y that dot
product is 0 the angle is 90 degrees the
cosine is 1 okay how to show well of
course I might be 0 how to how to show
that ya proof this is like just you can
tune out for 2 minutes if you hate
proofs ok I start with what I know and
what I know is in that box SX is lambda
X as one eigenvector that tells me the
eigenvector Y this tells me the eigen
values are different and that tells me
the matrix is symmetric I'm just gonna
juggle those four facts and I'll end up
with X transpose y equals 0 that's
orthogonal T okay so just I'll just do
it quickly - quickly so I take this
first thing and I transpose it turn it
into row vectors and then when I
transpose it that transposes transpose
means I flip rows and columns but for a
symmetric matrix no difference so s
transpose is the same as s and then I
look at this one and I multiply that by
X transpose both both sides by X
transpose what I end up with is
recognizing that lambda times that dot
product equals alpha times that dot
product but lambda is different from
alpha so the only way lambda times that
number can equal alpha times that number
is that number has to be 0 and that's
the answer ok so that's the proof that
used exactly every fact we knew end of
proof
main point to remember I convector czar
perpendicular when the matrix is
symmetric okay in that case now you
always want to express these facts as
from multiplying matrices that that's so
that says everything in a few symbols
where I had to use all those words on
the previous slide so this is that
that's the result that I'm shooting for
that symmetric matrix
yeah it just focus on that it's that box
a symmetric matrix can be broken up into
its eigenvectors those are in q its
eigenvalues those are the lambdas those
are the or the numbers lambda 1 to
lambda n on the diagonal lambda and then
the transpose so the eigenvectors are
now rows in q transpose that's just
perfect perfect every symmetric matrix
is an orthogonal matrix times a diagonal
matrix times the transpose of the
orthogonal matrix yeah that's called the
spectral theorem in it you could say
it's it's up there with the most
important facts in linear algebra and in
wider mathematics yeah so that's the
fact that that controls what we do yeah
what we do here oh now I have to say
what's the situation if the matrix is
not symmetric now I am NOT going to get
perpendicular eigenvectors that was a
symmetric thing mostly but I'll get on
vectors so I'll get ax equal lambda X
they just the first one won't be
perpendicular to the second one the
matrix a it has to be square or this
doesn't make sense so so eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are the way to break up a
square matrix into and and find this
diagonal matrix lambda with the
eigenvalues
- 1 lambda 2 2 lambda n that's that's
the purpose is an eigen vectors are
perpendicular when it's a symmetric
matrix otherwise I just have X n its
inverse matrix but none no symmetry ok
so that's the that's the quick
expression another factorization of
eigenvalues in lambda diagonal just
numbers and eigenvectors in the columns
of X ok and now I'm not going to oh I
was going to say I'm not going to solve
all the problems of applied math but
that's what these are for
let's just see what special hear about
these eigenvectors suppose I multiply
again by a I start with ax equal lambda
X now I'm gonna multiply both sides by a
that'll tell me something about eigen
values of a squared because when I
multiply by a so let me start with a
squared now times X which means a times
ax a times ax but ax is lambda X so I
have a times lambda X and I pull out
that number lambda so I said I still
have a 1 ax and that's also still lambda
X you see I'm just talking around in a
little circle here just using ax equal
lambda X a couple of times and the
result is do you see what that means
that result that means that the eigen
value for a squared same eigen vector X
the eigen value is lambda squared and if
I had a cubed the eigen value would come
out lambda cubed and if I have a to the
yeah yeah it's so if I had a 10 x + n
multiple so when would you have a to a
high power that's a interesting matrix
take a matrix and square it cubit take
high powers of it the eigen values the
eigen vectors don't change that's the
great thing that's the whole point of
in vectors they don't change and the
eigenvalues just get taken to the high
power so for example we could ask the
question when if I multiply a matrix by
itself over and over and over again when
do I approach zero well if these numbers
are below one so eigenvectors
eigenvalues gives you something that you
just could not see by those column
operations or l times you this is
looking deeper okay and okay
and then you'll see we have almost
already seen with least squares this
combination a transpose a so remember a
is is a rectangular matrix and by n i
multiply it by its transpose when i
transpose it i have n by m and when I
multiply them together I get n by n so a
transpose a is a is a four theory is a
great matrix a transpose times a it's
symmetric yeah let's just see what we
have about eight its square for sure oh
yeah this tells me that it's symmetric
and you remember why I'm always looking
for symmetric matrices because they have
those orthogonal eigenvectors they
they're the beauty beautiful ones for
eigenvectors and a transpose a
automatically symmetric you just you
know you just you you're multiplying
something by its its adjoint it's its
transpose and the result is that you you
know this matrix is symmetric and maybe
there's even more about they transpose a
yes
what is that here's a final i always
saying matrix certain matrices are
important but these are the winners
they're symmetric matrices if i want
beautiful matrices make them symmetric
and make the eigenvalues positive so
or rather than a nonnegative allows zero
so I can either say positive definite
when the eigenvalues are positive or I
can say non-negative which allows zero
and that and that so I have greater than
or equal to zero I just want to say that
that bringing all the pieces of linear
algebra come together in these matrices
and we're seeing the eigenvalue part of
it and here I've mentioned something
called the energy so that's a physical
quantity that also is greater or equal
to zero so that's a transpose a is the
matrix that I'm going to use in the
final part of this video to achieve
great the greatest factorization Q
lambda Q transpose was fantastic but for
our non square matrix it's not for a non
square matrix
they don't even have eigenvalues and
eigenvectors but data comes in non
square matrices data is about like we
have a bunch of diseases and a bunch of
patients or a bunch of medicines and the
number of medicines is not equal the
number of patients or diseases those are
different numbers so the matrices that
we see in data are rectangular and they
don't I can values don't make sense for
those and singular values take their
place of eigen values so singular values
and my hope is that linear algebra
courses 1806 for sure will always reach
after you to explain eigen values that
everybody agrees is important yet
singular values into the course because
they really have come on as the big
things to do in data so that would be
the last part of this summary video for
20/20 vision of linear algebra as they
get singular values in there okay that's
kind
next